let's welcome the next audience over
sheriff Kate Thompson Arthur
where are you from Kate I'm from here in
Los Angeles oh really yeah you kind of
have like an Indiana field okay well
from Michigan to welcome to crossing
over
that's perfect well you're lovely thank
you let's see which one is left that
one's mine ready hmm
Kate Compton I accidently mooned my boss
I was wearing loose-fitting have you say
that Gaucho Gaucho pants sounds like a
cold soup and somehow managed to step in
one of the legs this resulted in me
pulling down my own pants I turned
around to found my to find my boss
asking if there was a full moon out
tonight your boss that is such like a
cliche kind of sitcom line like Orko
is it a full night not any gee I'm sure
that was fine I'm sorry that hell yeah
that's terrible
it was it was I didn't wear underwear
that day laundry day
there's a sexy way to do it but there's
no Marilyn Monroe poster of the time she
put her grandson ere great
all that sort of stuff all right Kate
I'm terrified of my own but uh please
read my over Sheriff all right
when I was 12 I wrote my own Penthouse
Forum letters just for me and when I
when I finished pleasuring myself
taking myself on and JDate i would
immediately erase the letter from my
computer most of the scenes took place
on a yacht you know so weird you don't
think that's not weird well
take it easy Mooney to the 3k